all right they're gone ceremonial bagel
flag
[Music]
flames
let the games begin
welcome to the jimmy jabs we play for
pride
we play for the phone numbers of rosa's
friends but most importantly
we play to watch amy lose nope this is
my year
it's my year too please don't align
yourself with me why not neither of you
have ever come close to winning
you're exactly the same just a couple of
santiagos
but the real prize is the winchester
3000.
the only chair in the precinct with
minimal staining good lumbar support
and no broken rollie wheels over to you
gina
thank you jake okay guys as usual the
loser of each event is eliminated from
the games
the winner gets a bonus in the final
round
our first event is the mouth-a-thon
in front of you as month-old chinese
food from the fridge
go ahead and eat as much as you can
stomach
on your mark get set wahlberg
[Music]
oh i can't do this to my mouth
she's the love of my life charles is
eliminated
awesome i think this ball of soups is
off i'm out i can do this
i want to win so bad oh great here quick
let me take a picture
oh that's so cute you've got a little
bit of mold on the tip of your nose
i tried i tried but he is unbeatable
you guys know this is free right
the next event will be keep your cover
contestants must craft an undercover
persona
and talk to as many police officers as
you can
before being recognized pregnant nice
means you had sex damn right i did and i
forgot my birth control
yeah yeah i think the belly will draw
attention away from my face
smart like one big boob uh-huh jake will
go first then amy
then rosa on your mark get set paul
gossler
peralta what the hell where were you
i got eliminated excuse me officer
yeah sweetheart sweetheart seriously
hank is how you talk to women who come
in here
jimmy jabs i didn't even make it past
one person you're out i'm in the finals
and all i have to do to get katie's
number is beat amy that's nothing
hey don't you dare touch amy junior
that's right
it's your baby are you saying i knocked
you
up you sure did on your mark get seth
rogan contestants must make it
past the barricade hurdles then use a
beanbag gun to get a snack
you will eat the snack in its entirety
next head down to the first floor where
you will locate a pamphlet about
bullying then print out a picture of me
using a laptop from 1982.
whoever grabs their printout first is
the winner
[Music]
what are you doing santiago
no broken jolly wheel
i did it i took my time i wasn't a crazy
idiot and i
won i finally won
oh yeah yes
what's going on here ladies
and gentlemen the moment you've been
waiting for
wow you went full showman i present to
you six
freaks who through a series of elaborate
games will be eliminated
one by one until a champion is crowned
and that
champion shall inherit my circus
and get a day off i was getting there
row row let me have my fun yeah ro-ro
let him have his fun
as always we start the games by lighting
the ceremonial bagel of destiny ah it's
actually
the baguette of destiny because this
year we're throwing caution to the wind
charles flame me yeah hit me jabs
give me jazz
and with that we commence my 10-minute
opening performance
what the crowd is ready the freaks are
here
welcome to the first competition which
one of you
will meet your maker be sure not to
foul out or you will meet
your end we don't know what the game is
so these puns don't work it's a meat
throwing challenge
all of the expired coal cuts from the
kitchen refrigerator
are under this tarp voila
you will toss a meat of your choosing at
the break room window from
10 feet away if it sticks to the glass
well then you move on
if it doesn't then your cold cut yes now
you're giving it thank you rosa
jake sticks it amy sticks it
scully sticks it hitchcock sticks it
home old-school stick sips railroad
sticks it
debbie where's debbie
[Music]
i can't do this charles i didn't even
grab a meat i'm not some
expert cold-cut thrower like all of you
everyone i need a second for
freaking trouble debbie i once stood
here in front of this squad and felt
like i didn't belong but but
nothing this is your chance to do
something great debbie this is your
moment
take it and stick this meat
is this turkey yes i'm very allergic to
turkey
so debbie's out but shall we find thanks
for her purse full of epipens
and now that brings us to the end of
round one which means it is time
for another song it was the meat
of the moment meat meat meat of the
moment yeah we'll be back in five years
throw it at the window window window
welcome
to my most sadistic creation the tangled
nightmare of extension cords that lives
in our supply closet your mission
is to untangle your lamp's cord plug it
in
and then pull yourself to it on your
dolly and turn it on ah nice hitchcock's
coming down from the speed
i have a chance freaks begin
[Music]
what is that grab the top one and get
the bottom one oh my god that's what you
meant
although i'm open to whatever you want
to try here we go diaz i want to
apologize
i'm not talking to you oh oh
it worked the packing worked what no
here we go
gotcha you're never gonna catch me oh
yeah
yeah yes i did it and hitchhike's gonna
lose
rosa and holter gonna beat him rosa stop
i give up
i want you to know i'm sorry for prying
win this thing and enjoy your day off
and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal
just know i'm always here
okay i'd like that
what no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition some things are
more
important than a game no they're not
wait where are you going don't leave
we need you
oh why does the ceiling hate me
the obstacle course this is gonna be
rough turns out taking a ton of random
pills is
really bad for you everything hurts yeah
i'm like 50 50 gonna die
on your mark get set dazzle me freaks
first you must make your way past the
barricade hurdles
after the hurdles you must fish a dollar
coin out of our gross
clog up sink of nightmares
you'll use that money to buy a hot dog
after you eat the entire dog you'll
return to the break room where you must
extract an olive from the windpipe
behind like practice tummy
why are you using your mouth for
everything the winner will be the first
person to sit in the ring masters throne
oh surprise twist to get to the throne
you must break through a breech training
door what why are you making this so
hard on me it's all for the show
jake the greatest show on earth all
right fine i can do this
for my wife
[Music]
yeah it didn't work my skeleton feels
like it's made of skin also i can't do
it amy yes you can
okay you just need a little energy and
debbie's epipens are full of adrenaline
is that a smart thing to do probably not
but sometimes it's good to be a little
irresponsible that could make me sick
it's better than losing our car i mean
is it cause
[Music]
congratulations you inherit the circus i
did it
i don't want the circus
you